all right people
it is january 22nd 2021 i'm dave rubin
this is the reuben report direct message
we are
streaming live from los angeles on
youtube and on blaze tv and we're doing
another panel show this week we've
we've done one of these and you guys dug
it and i dug it so we said we're gonna
do it again because we're people
pleasers around here
joining me today for the panel are dr
seb gorka who's the former deputy
assistant to the president and host of
america
first i'll be on his show a little bit
later today uh sean spicer who's the
former white house communications
director and host of spicer and company
on newsmax i don't think i'm on that
today but i'm on all the time
and jack murphy author of democrat to
deplorable and founder of liminal order
and a guy i've wanted on the show
forever so gentlemen welcome to the
reuben report
thanks for having me happy friday all
right
let's start with the doctor dr gorka
because
uh you've got doctor in front of you and
if jill biden's a doctor we're all
doctors
uh the reason i wanted to have the 3u on
basically is because not only did you
and sean
work in the administration but jack has
a similar political evolution as me he
was a democrat for a long time
i jack i'll let you speak for yourself
but basically i think you're a
conservative at this point or at least
sort of a
a non-democrat let's say uh and i
thought bringing the three of you guys
on to discuss what the future of this
thing is would be interesting
gorka what do you think the future of
the republicans is is it is it a trump
future
or are they going back to all the other
guys
well i'll tell you one thing it better
not be a third party dave so
um that would be a disaster that's how
we got bill clinton when
ross perot ran uh against uh
clinton and split the conservative vote
uh look i i listened to my
my sources uh i had one of the new
freshman congresswoman on my show
lauren bobbitt who's already created
quite a name for herself who said
on my show america first this is donald
trump's
party now i don't know what he's gonna
do in 2024 i was there at andrews air
force base
with sean uh on uh the morning of the
inauguration we saw the president saw
the first lady and he said right there
in front of us
i will in one shape or form or another
i will be back now whether he runs or
not i don't know
but for the foreseeable future he will
be the conservative king maker
not only that the mega movement it's not
just about him
it's about what he came to represent it
was remarkable
well i saw it with my own eyes so did
shawn this is a man who appealed
across all class structures across all
demographics when you go to
youngstown ohio steel valley and you see
people from the steel industry
former democrats whose grandparents were
democrats
screaming you know america first america
first usa
that's like reagan and that that has
changed conservative politics uh
inexorably so the the gop establishment
the mitch mcconnell type establishment
i think is dead god bless donald trump
for doing that
yeah i'm kind of with you on that and
and whatever this thing becomes it has
to be bigger
than one man sean since uh since he
chose you at one time
to to represent his thoughts trump's
thoughts that is
to to the people um do you think
whatever this movement now is uh that is
that we're all being told we all have to
be deprogrammed and de-platformed and
the rest of it
um can it survive without trump does it
does it actually need the man or can the
ideas of it
survive i mean it can't survive sure but
i would just say that steps right i mean
if it goes the way of a third party
that's disaster um
and it literally guarantees a democratic
majority going forward for a generation
parties are bigger than just ideas
they're about mechanics they're about
getting on ballots and
and um and we've seen this with the
green party and the libertarian party
whatever there's a reason that we have a
two-party system and
part of it is just because there there's
an there's an apparatus
uh that is necessary to get on all 50
states ballots and to be
organized and and to run the
imaginations of this
but to get to your question whether he
plays king maker candidate that's up to
donald trump
to decide uh for himself but what
trump represented is he tapped into this
feeling and sediment that existed in
america and though it's
it still exists there were 75 million
people who voted for him
um and so if you're a smart politician
you should look at what he did and what
he represented and say hey
i get that there are people out there
that think washington ignores them that
don't think that washington gets the
issues and the concerns that they have
and i want to tap into it you don't need
to be like trump trump is trump
let him do it but politicians need to
understand that what what made trump
trump was an authenticity
and an understanding of the struggles
that people go through and you can't
fake that
yeah can i add to something very briefly
so and exactly what sean said let's
remember one thing
i mean quite stunning that despite the
calumny
despite the libel of the last four years
where
24 7 he was called a misogynist a white
supremacist
an islamophobe and then a nazi literally
a nazi
he got 10 million more votes than he did
four years ago
and that's not because of mitch that's
not because of kevin mccarthy
that's because of donald trump's message
so the fact that he got more votes than
any other president
is the determining factor not his
personage but the message of making
america great again
so jack as the new guy to the party
literally and figuratively i i feel like
you've had a pretty good handle on
uh like sort of the underbelly of the
internet side of this just
what's going on that kind of average
people are saying on
twitter and on youtube and the rest of
it what do you make of the situation
yeah my you know my perspective is
definitely more grassroots than these
other two gentlemen for sure
and i think the first thing i want to
talk about is just remembering that maga
is an emergent network it is a
phenomenon that bubbled up
from the people and and the network
elected donald trump to represent
that network and that energy and that
energy still survives
the the maga energy the moga network
that launched donald trump into power
is still here and the democrats
acknowledge that i mean whether or not
what they did with the
the armed truth capital was justified on
a
security level or justified in their
mind on an info-op level
they recognized the need to make a
strong display uh in the face of 75
million people who did support the
president
and do support that that the maga energy
now my question is
uh to the other two panelists to seb and
sean here is
you know is trump really in charge of
the gop i don't see it
when when i was when i was looking at
the stage in 2016
looking at the primaries i saw him
defeat 17 of the gop
but i think the gop defeated donald
trump while he was in office
and i don't see him taking over the gop
as it stands i still see him contra the
gop and still battling
the gop which is really just the
uniparty and that's what the maga energy
was all about fighting back against
the corporate uniparty in cahoots with
the democrats and the gop establishment
plus the corporations black lives matter
and for a moment there
uh antifa as well but that's what needs
to happen here in the future i think
yeah so that's a good point it's
something i've been talking about all
week that what we saw really is just
that the swamp
just kind of reconstituted itself that
the swamp just
kind of loves itself so sean as a guy
that lives in dc you've been around
the swamp for a long time when you see
guys like mitch mcconnell sort of
reconstituting the swamp and now saying
maybe he'll be for impeachment which
it's like
just let the guy leave at this point
that would be my opinion like we've
if there's anything that's going to be
healing in this country which i'm not
sure there actually is
it's like it would start without it
would start by not doing a
post-presidency
impeachment but but what do you make of
what jack just said there that
that the whole machinery is still not
part of what trump is
so it's like the republicans sort of
still are against him in a way
yeah i think jack's got a really good
point and that was the beauty of it that
trump tapped into the sediment that
existed out there
and was able to harness it and defeat
all these folks and but that's my point
though
is that i think jack's right but if
you're a smart
leader which apparently not all of them
seem to be that smart
that that they should understand that he
tapped into something
look seb made the point if trump wasn't
doing what people wanted his vote goal
would go
down in fact it went up that would tell
anybody
on the republican side hey he was
tapping into something and it was
something that was growing
so don't be a dummy understand how to do
what he was doing to
to tap into the sediment to understand
the concerns and the issues that he was
championing
and actually continue to move forward on
them um
because i i will say this he did shape
some things though you think about the
policy on trade
right the the republican party has
generally been
fairly you know just unabashedly free
trade
trump made people reconsider this and
say yes you can be
for you know fair trade and open trade
with restrictions and we're not giving
the house away this idea of putting
america first
made sense to people once they thought
about it but for so long literally
decades
we have been told well unfortunately
that's the way it has to be
what trump showed whether his domestic
policy or foreign policy
was like screw that we can actually do
it a different way
and achieve better results so i i just i
i agree with i will say this that
the leaders in congress need to
understand that
if they want to go back to the ways that
they were
they can do that and maybe that will
last for two or four years
but they are holding the water back in a
dam that is going to crumble on them
yeah that i completely agree with it's
like the cat is out of the bag
you know this thing has whatever is
happening in this country like no one
no one buys the swamp thing anymore seb
if if
trump just goes to mar-a-lago and is
just like you know what i gave it all i
got i got
i don't want to do this anymore or or at
least i don't want to run maybe i'll
if they let me back on twitter i'll do
what i can on that front or i'll do some
public events
um who's there is there somebody that
you're tracking is there a young
star that's coming like who who is on
the docket
i don't see it you know i just don't see
the bench some people
talk about cotton some people talk about
gates some people talk about
uh a greg abbott i just don't see it
because they're all politicians to a
lesser or greater extent
the re i mean let's just remember one
thing what happened in 2016. now we
forget this
it is truly historic for the first time
in
the republic's history we chose a
non-politician and a non-swarm dweller
from george washington to barack obama
every single one of the 44 presidents of
our republic
was either a retired general a former
governor
a senator a congressman for the first
time ever we
picked a non-politician who'd never run
for
public office before and that is the
future
they don't want somebody they've seen in
front of the tv cameras reading from
teleprompters for the last four or
16 years and to be clear to what jack's
point i said it when i was in the white
house i said it since i left the white
house and they don't like me in the
swamp for saying it but it is
it is patently obvious that donald trump
became president despite the gop
not thanks to the gop and the idea that
mitch mcconnell is acquiescing
to this trial of a private citizen is an
outrage
and the establishment gop four years
later still doesn't understand
what happened in 2016 and they will pay
a political penalty if they don't wake
up
and smell the coffee grinds jack what do
you think is
is going on in the minds of the people
that are you know everyone's political
now which is a very bizarre thing that
everyone is hyper political and obsessed
by it all the time and i think that's
partly why
everyone is so crazy and angry but what
do you make of like the people that are
the new ones to politics like i know you
went to some of the rallies i was at the
rally and
a couple of them in beverly hills and
what i liked about it was not only that
people were happy and fun but it was
clear that these are not political
people these were people who were just
like oh there's something kind of cool
and fun happening here
what do you think those people are
thinking right now yeah i think that
i think to just follow up on what's
being said recently that
the trump was defeated by the gop in in
his term
while he was president the biggest
obstacle he faced was the gop was
staffing was having loyal people
uh to carry out his plans at any of the
any of the agencies in the government
and so he lost the gop the gop is still
in power the democrats are still in
power the corporate unit party's still
in power
and so who's going to be next what's
next is somebody
who can bring the power that is
necessary
to circumvent the political parties and
to capture the party in the same way
that trump did
so i would look to somebody in the
future who is already bringing with them
a network power somebody that has their
own built-in communications and
distribution system
who understands persuasion who has
contacts across the country in every
industry and has
a brand people with outside brands have
to come in
and take over the political apparatus in
the same way that trump did
but again that will also lead to
additional infighting and
obstruction and derailment of that
candidate's agenda so that is
something that we have to deal with
right there that that contradiction
yeah so so i'm actually with you i'm
with you on that but so are you talking
about like
it's not this person specifically but
are you saying someone like it has to be
someone like elon musk like it has to be
like
someone who is really extraordinarily
connected and powerful
and has done all this stuff before in
terms of building things and all that or
you mean you mean like a youtuber like
like what do you actually mean i mean
somebody that can
bring the power to bear that's necessary
to communicate directly with the
american people
to get elected through a popular
election and then
somehow be able to implement their
network on top of or in place of the gop
institution because this is the
institutions that are the issue
we need new networks to battle the
captured institutions
okay this is let's go sorry go ahead uh
sean go ahead you were trying to get in
there no i just
the one thing that i was going to say
that that you know and i don't want to
take this off
off the track but i i think the problem
with this party
is that they've got to understand what
trump showed i always said what what
what was unique about trump
is in washington dc there's three power
centers right you have the the lobbyists
the journalists
and the sort of the the pundits and
elites that have always been used to no
matter who was
the next person in line always got
sucked up to and trump basically during
the campaign said
listen here's the deal i don't need you
i don't need your money and i don't need
you writing about me
if you want to jump on the bandwagon
you're welcome to but you know i don't
need you
that was the first time that frankly
anybody has said that there is a default
in the republican party right now
that i've witnessed for 30 years and
frankly to some degree
you know may have flirted with this
myself until i
recognize but that people want to be
accepted
they want the new york times to write a
puff piece about them they want to get
invited to the cocktail parties
and as soon as folks on the right
recognize that's never going to happen
and it's something that donald trump
enlightened us
on that if we realize it's never gonna
happen they will never accept us they
will never like us they will never bring
us into that fold
and that we need to be you know okay
with that and say screw it i don't need
to do that
once we understand that i think we as a
party can move in the right direction
but there is such a degree of the
republican party that wants to be
accepted
by this left-wing elite class that rules
the social circuit in the the media
circuit in dc
yeah for the record i have completely
given up on being invited to nice
parties
i am i am past the point of parties and
the rest of it and i'm also
locked in my house here in la so that's
a whole other thing but
let's talk about the the social media
component of this can i can i just jump
on this for a second
because this is a massive massively
important i feel i feel like i'm doing a
vulcan mind meld with jack and sean so
it is stunning
um that this phenomenon still exists
when when i was in the white house and
sean and i were were
the weird guys we were the oddities
because we didn't want the establishment
to say nice stuff about us
i mean i said you know if the washington
post
ever says something nice about sebastian
gorka
i'm failing i am utterly failing because
they're committed to the destruction of
this president
and his agenda so you know they want to
be loved
they were people at my rank deputy
assistant to the president which is
pretty high there's
40 people of that rank in the us are in
the u.s government
we outrank three-star generals i knew
people at my rank
dave who were never trumpers
inside the white house who were there
because they wanted the tick on the
resume
but were actively trying to undermine
the president so this this is
this question of bench and team i mean
jack is right that he has to be an
outsider and a celebrity
but it has to be somebody who can fill
four thousand political appointments
us government so i mean so one last
thing on that though is then is that
in your opinion is that was that trump's
fault like was that his greatest fault
is that he did not get rid of
the right people when he was supposed to
get rid of him no no no it's not that he
didn't get rid of them he didn't have
anybody to fill those positions when we
came in i went to work
the day after the inauguration saturday
january the 21st 8 a.m
and and you know we came into the
building and i'm not joking it's not an
exaggeration
there were about maybe 20 guys in senior
positions guys and gals and i mean
senior positions
who knew what maga meant were loyal to
magga not the man but to the message
make america great again
and had the wherewithal to actually make
something happen
then there was this gap and there were
like dozens and dozens and hundreds of
23 year olds
and then there was nobody else there was
no bench we were a small group of merry
men
it was like robin hood's insurgency took
off the took over the us government
thanks to the american people and then
we had to fill these positions and what
happened and i'm gonna let the you know
the dirty laundry out here we had to
fill thousands of positions and what
happened
the bushy schlep came in and filled the
vacuum the former bush appointees
or people who weren't competent came in
for those 4 000
positions where else would donald trump
get that team
and this is a massive problem for the
next four years we
must build the bench on the outside
and it can't come from these stinking
think tanks of so-called elitist
you know experts here in dc yeah so that
i think gets to jack's point about you
got to have a network and you're going
to have to have done a lot of stuff
before the next guy comes in but let's
talk about the
the information war here in the social
media component of this
because there are an awful lot of
mainstream people
right now on in new york times cnn
katie couric that we've been covering
all this stuff all these people that's
saying
that are saying that guys like us we're
spreading misinformation
we should be de-platformed we should be
banned we should take out newsmax we
should be kicked off youtube
there was a big article now about
podcasts or the next frontier on this
thing that we should all be silenced
um jack i know you're you're sort of on
the ground on this thing
it's like are they going to come for
everybody
i mean we're all feeling it january 6
was a day that
sort of settled it said in stone that uh
there was a insurgency we now gone from
being
uh nazis and racists to being domestic
terrorists
uh we know that uh the democrats are
going to look at not only are they
they're on an eradication mission in the
first place so they're just looking for
an excuse
to double down on what they wanted to do
in the first place which is to get rid
of us which is to make sure quote that
this never
happens again and that's what that big
display was around the inauguration
that the big display of force they want
to come for us they're going to come for
us and my advice to people is to take
your head off the chopping block of
social media
find a private network get involved put
up a
barrier between you and the rest of the
people keep your head down and build
deep roots
we are in a reconsolidation period at
least for this first year here
uh coming out of the four years of trump
we don't know exactly what's going to
happen with the censorship
and the online stuff so my advice to
everybody is to find a network a private
network
build your own in network be intentional
with your relationships and your
associations
put up a wall and keep the people out
that you want to keep out and put the
people inside that you want to
put inside and make sure it's based on
your shared values and i think
that that is a way to at least move
forward for the time being
you could call it something like locals
right yeah well i think
i think jack i think you yeah well i
think you mean it both
you mean it physically like in your
actual real world life remember that
real world life thing
but i think you mean it also also
digitally sean are you
kind of worried that they could just
come and take out newsmax it's like in
the old days it was like all right i'm
not an independent guy so they can take
out all the small fish they can
knock out some random youtubers that's
one thing but now they're literally
talking about going after oann going
after newsmax you know
getting licenses taken away and the rest
of it do you feel like you have extra
protections right now
no i mean i i if you had asked me this
question
six weeks ago eight weeks ago i would i
would think that that was it was a nutty
question
uh but in light of what's happened the
conversation that's occurred over the
last seven to ten days
yeah i'm really worried i think we've
gotten to the point where
um i mean the idea that you look at a
network and a network that is on these
you know major stations it's pulling in
close to a million people a night
and they go yeah we don't like what's
being said and by the way the thing
that's funny
is is that they never give the example
they said newsmax is
is just you know is part of the
disinformation campaign i'm like okay
tell me one thing that's been on my show
um you know conversations with you and
other people about news of the day that
somehow
they just don't even like the topics
they're like but but wait i just what i
don't get though dave and this is what's
fascinating
yesterday for example cnn 23
times said that the administration the
incoming administration was not left a
vaccine plan
none and that they had to quote start
from scratch dr fauci himself came out
and said that that was not true
cnn just moved on why aren't we talking
about deep platforming cnn
well because cnn is owned by att what is
att owned they own time water and
directv
these guys that hold the keys in the
corporate headquarters there is no doubt
in my mind
they're gonna get woke over and over
again to the idea of canceling out
stop allowing people to do this cancel
out advertisers
it's coming and i am worried yeah and
the best is when you see how obvious
their coordination is so
the messaging coming out of cnn on all
their twitter accounts yesterday
was the trump team was handed a
non-existent plan that's what they all
kept saying but
you can't be handed something that's
non-existent i mean that's not even
it doesn't even make any sense on top of
the fact that we know that something
like 17 million people
have gotten the vaccination and the
states are doing a lot of it and
all that stuff uh seb i'm guessing
you're worried too although you don't
strike me as a particularly nervous type
of guy but you're worried about
the hammer dropping on on all of us in
terms of our ability to communicate
i look it's gonna happen sooner or later
but i don't
lose sleep over it you know it's easy
for me when you got a dad who
you know had the scars on his body till
his dying day of of the torture that the
secret police did to him in a in a
dictatorial regime before he escaped
from a political prison i just
bring it you bastards just bring it
because sooner or later those types of
regimes and i mean regimes
fail and when you've got 74 million
people who voted for a man who believes
in america who loves america and who
believes in freedom of speech who didn't
spy on american journalists like obama
did
didn't put journalists in their sources
in prison
then sooner or later there will be a
backlash and this isn't a threat it's a
fact i taught for six years
irregular warfare and counterinsurgency
for the defense department
and when you silence people with true
grievances
sooner or later something will occur and
the idea that we're going to run and
hide from it is
utterly un-american and and you're right
there is a coordination here remember
michelle obama michelle obama
writes a two-page letter that donald
trump should be d-platformed
and 72 hours later he is deleted he's
unpersoned by jack dorsey
and then we see the video from the
twitter meeting
thanks to veritas project saying jack's
saying
if this isn't just about one account
this is about
lots of accounts and it's going to last
a long time
you've experienced it i've lost 100 000
followers in 10 days
but do i give up do we do it do we give
up no we persevere
because sooner or later more and more
americans even in the middle the a
most americans are apolitical we'll see
the fascistic tendencies
of the democrat party and we'll
understand what you understood
when you left the democrats that this is
not your daddy's great democrat party
this is not your granddaddy's
democrat party and it is now a bunch of
radicals who are hostage to their own
radical extremism well that's a perfect
segue to jack here because you wrote the
book democrat to deplorable what do you
make
of the people that we used to hang out
with all the time because
they're not all bad i know they're not
all bad we all know that they're not all
bad
but i have been if there's one group
that i'm just supremely disappointed
with right now
it's it's my old crew it's the last few
remaining decent liberals who i saw
celebrating i mean many of them who've
been on this show
celebrating the censorship of donald
trump
what do you make of that crew at this
point it's it's tough man in the 90s you
know i was counter culture in washington
dc
i like to do underground parties and i
was anti-establishment
and as i grew up i think i retained that
and what i see from my old friends that
are all still democrats
they they think they're
anti-establishment but they are the
establishment now and they're and
they're just not aware
of the fact and they've lost all of
their rebel or punk attitude that they
had
and they're just toeing the line and
truly deep down inside i believe that
they're just not informed and that if i
could
i know it's fruitless and i know it's
hopeless but i swear if i could just
just get into their head just a little
bit and help them see what i see
i just feel like i'm ahead of the game
and i do believe that we did see
an expansion in the democrat to
deplorable vote there were 9 million
in 2016. i believe that that group got
bigger in this last election
there are people that we've seen just
online on twitter folks that that were
anti-trump in the first
go around that that were convinced uh
united mostly behind being anti-woke and
anti-critical race theory etc
but i think what might happen and and
sub you use the word
fascistic i'm ready to say it is declare
it is a
techno corporate fascism that we live
under
a uniparty united with the corporations
acting in concert to silence people
to take away their human rights their
right to free speech to unperson them to
exile them
when the government and the corporations
are acting in tandem
to take away your human rights that is
fascism
that is fascism bingo and we need to be
talking about this more often and not in
the hysterical way that the people were
calling as fascists before
but in a very serious clinical way and i
think
i'm hoping maybe and i still have an
extinguished optimist in me
that that center group that people that
that went democrats are deplorable
the walk away folks that that that is
where we need to be focusing our energy
as
chipping people off and here's what's
going to happen i think there are going
to be more red pills delivered to the
more
normal american people uh throughout
this year and it's going to come in the
form of critical race theory
and it's going to come when they're
attacking your children when they're
telling your eight-year-old
daughter that she needs to sit with her
whiteness and suffer because of it and
renounce her
her color and step aside and yield
positions of power to people of color
that is when the red pilling of middle
america is really going to take place
and i can see more of that coming uh in
2021 and beyond i
i totally hear you on that and i
actually
for for those dems that it's like you
want to wake them up i think a lot of
them actually are also playing a bit of
a duplicitous game which is they know
how dangerous this thing is
they know it's coming for all of them
but they just don't want to be put on
the list right they don't want to be
thought of as one of the guys in these
in these four boxes that we got here uh
but
but dave it's it's like what the thing
that's interesting to me is that
the folks on the left they've always had
this issue you talk they love to preach
about the
the value and the virtue of public
school but then they send their kids to
private school
all these folks on the left that are so
woke they want everything else they just
want conservatives to do that they don't
really want that themselves i don't
think that they believe that
they just want others to do it and to
believe it so that they can feel good
well it's like it's like the healing
right we can heal now that they got what
they want
if if it had gone the other way they
would not be talking about healing but
my whole audience knows i try to i try
to leave everybody at the end of a show
with something positive so they don't
feel crazy and i i really feel like i
got to give it to him on a friday
so uh to wrap up seb i'll start with you
what's the silver lining here what's the
silver lining
the silver lining is that we're america
and we've
we've survived and persevered and and
flourished through much
much harder times and every
here's the real silver lining and i get
a little pissed when people dm me
send me texts and emails i've given up
that's it america's gone
and my response and you can take it
personally if you like
because i chose this country i'm a legal
immigrant and my response is this
despair is un-american
the founding fathers didn't do it in
1775 they took action
we didn't do it after almost 3 000
americans were murdered in just a few
minutes on
pearl harbor we didn't do it on
september 11th though so guys
buckle up pull up your bootstraps
and understand that america is not a
function of who's in the white house
america is a function of who you are and
whether you
are true to american values so we can do
it
we just have to be true to ourselves uh
i just screwed you guys
because that was a nice ending now
you're going to really have to bring it
jack jack take it away i'm going to give
the former press secretary a moment to
collect his thoughts
you know the secret line the silver
lining here is that
people like us our network we have
what's called a faster ooda loop
we can observe orient decide and act and
change our course of action and adapt
and implement our ingenuity in a way
much more much quicker
and with much more effectiveness than
the other side and so i believe in that
power
i believe that we are going to adapt and
react and one of the best benefits that
i've seen
is that i have been urging people and
we've been creating intentional
communities
of reaching out and finding people that
share your values
find common values and build with them
build a community build a network live
work and play with people that share
your values they don't even have to live
next door to you anymore
take advantage of the connectivity and
reach out and find those people
a renaissance of intentional communities
across america as we ooda faster than
the enemy
and we make our way towards the next
round of elections i know one of these
right-wing maniacs is
building something called locals.com
that's doing just that i forget
crazy guy crazy guy all right sean
former press secretary give everybody
something on a friday
boom uh all right i'm going to dovetail
off both of them i will tell you two
things
one is when i was out doing dancing with
the stars initially it scared the heck
out of me because i was sitting
a i was like wow i'm really bad at this
and two i'm in a place where they
probably hate my guts
and what i realized in that show was
that
i needed to stop thinking that that was
the case because
as you saw i advanced to the
quarterfinals of a show
where i was horrible but people rallied
there are more people every time that
you think that we're the 20
if you look at the vote that donald
trump got we're still the 50
we're there and we've got to stop
thinking that we're this minority and
that there's nobody else out there
when i told people about how important
the georgia election were in this
dovetails on what seb was saying people
go i'm giving up i'm giving up
too much is at stake there are plenty of
us if we mobilize and do what jack's
talking about
get out there not be afraid of what we
stand for
fight for our values and mobilize we can
win
stop being a bunch of babies that are
negative about the opportunity
and the options in the up in the future
there is enough of us
that believe in conservative values and
principles that if we get out there and
we fight hard
and we explain why our principles and
values are better for this country and
our families and our communities
we will win but the second that we give
up and the second that we let them
cancel us
they win not bad man
you had a high bar and mainstream
i googled that that was biden
[Laughter]
mainstream political thought has been
dumbed down to the point that your
analogy about dancing with the stars
actually makes complete sense to me it
really does it's like you just gotta do
it and you see who comes along
guys i really enjoyed this i hope you
did too we're going to do plenty more of
these so i hope you'll join us again
i'm going to let you guys go and then
i'm going to i'm going to finish up solo
here have a great day guys
and i'll see you i'll see you soon
all right everybody uh i hope you
enjoyed that i really like these i feel
like the energy is good we'll keep
trying to mix up the panelists
and yes i promise you i will try to get
more people on the left and i will try
to get more centrist than everything
else
but i do want to address that exact
point for just a moment because i know
it seems oh here he had these right-wing
conservatives on
right and okay it's more right-wing
conservatives
but what i'm really starting to believe
and i've been saying this for quite some
time and and i think it was partly why i
was supporting trump
who i liked the ideas of maybe more than
the man himself
was that the stuff that we just talked
about did any of that seem extreme to
you to you did any of that seem
dangerous to you did any of that seem
like things that
were promoting misinformation or
disinformation or that were against
america or
your freedom or any of those things the
answer is no so what's really odd
is when people say okay well we should
we should all be more in the center
i think in essence what's happened is
that conservatives basically are the new
center
uh it doesn't mean that you have to be
conservative like oh here are the ten
conservative things and you have to
absolutely be
all these things as you know guys i'm
begrudgingly pro-choice and i make that
argument in my book that is definitely
not
something that is thought of as
conservative i'm against the death
penalty
that is not something that is thought of
as conservative um
there are some conservatives that are
not uh okay with gay marriage i'm
married to a gay dude i mean
there are some things and yet i
absolutely would consider myself a new
conservative so i think
i think there's sort of a misnomer that
you know everyone that had anything to
do with trump or that's on any of these
channels
or on fox news that that's somehow far
right it's it's very it's ultra you know
this new ultra conservative these are
nazis and terrorists and the rest of it
and i actually think it's most of us i
think it's most of us that just want to
live free and want to agree to disagree
and find some people to talk to so i
promise you
i will continue to find people that are
say more left of me or more in line with
some of this stuff or that are biden
supporters or if there's anyone on the
at the administration that wants to talk
to me we'll we'll reach out by the way
we reached out to the trump people and
we'll continue to reach out to uh
to to people at the biden administration
and all that um
but i do think that in a weird way what
we just did
is the new center but i'd love to know
your thoughts on it so let me know at
rubenreport.locals.com and i really do
think that jack is correct whether it's
online or real life the answer to this
is figuring out what your networks are
and and not being so reliant on big tech
not being so reliant on all the things
that have always existed because they're
failing right
social justice and all of this stuff is
infecting all of these things and that's
why everything's kind of crumbling so
figure out what your local communities
are i mean when i open that freaking app
the reuben report app the locals app and
i go into that community
it's like there are there are now
thousands of great people and they're
communicating
there are people who've gone on dates
there are several people who've now
invested in locals and work for us and
we've hired other people and a whole
bunch of other stuff
there's really cool stuff going on but
i'm not making a sales pitch for that
whatever your local community is that
you care about
whether it's in your town or online like
find it and that's that is how
we'll strengthen each other and get
through this craziness uh reminder my
interview with jason
reilly from the manhattan institute uh
is up right now and he just put out a
fantastic documentary that actually
debuts this weekend
about thomas soul and yours truly makes
a cameo or two in it and they use some
of our
interview with dr sol it's really it's
really a wonderful thing and his book on
it is coming out
in a month or two and that's it maybe
don't be ultra political this weekend
go out hang out with people if you're
here in la do something illegal like
have dinner with friends
and i'll see you guys on monday